Poe is someone that does it for
attention
what up guys welcome to the just curly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
whiteboard videos today I am going to go
over the hierarchy of Florida before I
start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification Bell
that way you're gonna be notified of my
daily videos so this last week I decided
that I wanted to know more about [__]
[__] hoes nice ladies and oh I forgot
ladies and wifey material so this week
we did a show where we really wanted to
define the terms because a lot of men
out there cannot Define what's a [__]
what's a [__] what's a whole lot of the
women it's like what is this and I'd
like to tell you guys in 2023 if we go
by a historical point of view 95 of
women would be horse however we are in
2023 so we got to adapt to the time so I
surveyed some men to see what they
thought the definition that we came up
with was a [__] is someone that has sex
for money or does [__] things for
money a [__] is someone who does it for
sex and a hoe is someone that does it
for attention so we went through some
scenarios as a class a [__] isn't only
fans worker a stripper a hooker or an
escort I think I spelled escort around
wrong but never mind that a [__] is a
woman feeds on her boyfriend one
nightstands because what's she doing it
for next we have a hoe now this is a
girl ass picks on the gram okay or 15
plus bodies now okay guys there's been a
lot of dispute some guys are saying no
it's way less than that I I just asked
the people I just I just report the news
let me know if there's anything else we
should add to the top three but that's
what we got for now so then we have a
lady so a lady can have roughly 5 to 14
bodies okay but she cannot have gotten
these through one night stands so no one
night stands you can only have gotten
the bodies you maybe you got ghosted
took it now but you could still be a
lady you have five to fourteen bodies
now let's define a nice lady zero to
five bodies is a nice lady and wifey is
a virgin is wife material so now that we
have some definitions what I wanted to
do was I wanted to make a hierarchy of
Horror them now I'm just repeating back
to you what the markets don't shoot the
messenger okay ladies all right so here
we have the least desirable here we have
the most desirable and most rare So what
is going to go on the least desirable
level in terms of sluttiness this is the
hierarchy of whoredom all right so at
the bottom we have hookers now there's
many names for these ladies hookers
um escort escorts
um Street Walkers night walkers but at
the end of the day they're selling for
money we have porn stars now because
they're not just straight selling sex
they have less Partners but porn stars
are above hookers only fans ladies
you're not at the bottom but you're not
far from it you're just above hookers
porn stars then only fans next we have
strippers now A Stripper can go on to
live a normal life because there's no
maybe maybe he didn't sell sex for money
I mean we all know what goes on in the
strip clubs but maybe she just stripped
so then now this is the most disputed
one I asked the men what's worse would
you rather take a single mother or a
woman with a high body count now we all
know that they're single mothers with
high body count like we all know but I
said you have to pick one and the men
picked drum roll please
high body count if you sleep with too
many people you are barely better than a
stripper now what number this is is very
disputed across the board
um I I've heard numbers like around 25
at switches they'd rather take a single
mom I've had some guys say 10 I've had
some guys say 30. I don't know when it
switches exactly for men but let's just
say somewhere between 15 to 30 they'll
take the kid over the bodies don't shoot
the messenger now remember if you have
both you're lower but if you just have a
kid and not the body count you're
slightly above the horse but not by much
I mean hoes these are hoes baby [__]
baby [__] the hoes and the [__] and
remember level of ladies are mid body
counts so again I've had some dispute
but what I've gotten is like five to
like 15 roughly men will take that over
the kid but it switches around there
then we have love low body count which
nowadays is like under 10 under five
again please don't shoot the messenger
I'm just repeating back what I've been
told and at the top version this is the
hierarchy of whoredom from Lee [__]
um let me know if there's anything I
forgot guys you know I love giving these
lessons to you don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification and I will talk to you guys
next time